Meet SCP-2662, also known as Cthulhu. Believe
us, he’s really not what you’re expecting.
The primary anomalous effect of Cthulhu is warping
the minds of random civilians out there in the
world, and causing them to independently
form highly dangerous and depraved cults.
These cults will do everything they can to
break into the low-security humanoid wing
where SCP-2662 is contained in an attempt to
free him, and also perform depraved blood and
sex rituals in his name. The SCP Foundation has
consistently been unable to stop them getting in.
The problem is, at only a few hundred
years old, Cthulhu is practically a
teenager by his own standards. He isn’t
interested in joining any of these cults,
and in fact finds them pretty creepy
and disgusting. He submitted himself
for Foundation containment voluntarily, and they
keep him safe from the weirdos who worship him.